[intense music]
- HI, EVERYBODY,
I’M DAVE STASSEN ALONGSIDE GEOFF
WORTHING, AND WELCOME
TO THE ANNUAL EAST/WEST BOWL,
AS WE GET READY TO WATCH
SOME OF THE BEST COLLEGE PLAYERS
IN THE NATION SHOWCASE
THEIR SKILLS IN A CLASSIC
SHOWDOWN BETWEEN EAST AND WEST.
AND THERE REALLY
ARE SOME CHARACTERS
ON THIS YEAR’S SQUADS,
AREN’T THERE, GEOFF?
- THAT’S RIGHT, DAVE.
IT DOES SEEM LIKE THE MOST
FLAMBOYANT PERSONALITIES
CAME TO THE FOREFRONT,
AND THEY ARE HERE.
LET’S MEET THE PLAYERS
FROM THE EAST. [rock music]
- D’MARCUS WILLIUMS,
UNIVERSITY OF GEORGIA.
- T.J. JUCKSON,
WAYNE STATE UNIVERSITY.
- T’VARIUSNESS KING,
MERRIMACK COLLEGE.
- TYROIL SMOOCHIE-WALLACE,
UNIVERSITY OF MIAMI.
- D’SQUARIUS GREEN, JR.,
UNIVERSITY OF NOTRE DAME.
- IBRAHIM MOIZOOS, UNIVERSITY
OF TENNESSEE AT CHATTANOOGA.
- JACKMERIUS TACKTHERITRIX,
MICHIGAN STATE UNIVERSITY.
- D’ISIAH T. BILLINGS-CLYDE,
COASTAL CAROLINA UNIVERSITY.
- [lisping]
D’JATHPER PROBINCRUX THE THIRD,
THOUTH CAROLINA
THTATE UNIVERTHITY.
- LEOZ MAXWELL JILLIUMZ,
EAST CAROLINA UNIVERSITY.
- JAVARIS JAMAR JAVARISON-LAMAR,
UNIVERSITY OF MIDDLE TENNESSEE.
- DAVOIN SHOWER-HANDEL,
UNIVERSITY
OF SOUTHERN MISSISSIPPI.
- HINGLE MCCRINGLEBERRY,
PENN STATE UNIVERSITY.
- L’CARPETRON DOOKMARRIOT,
FLORIDA ATLANTIC UNIVERSITY.
- J’DINKALAGE MORGOONE,
UNIVERSITY OF SOUTH FLORIDA.
- XMUS JAXON FLAXON-WAXON,
CALIFORNIA UNIVERSITY
OF PENNSYLVANIA.
- WE’RE GOING TO BE LOOKING
FOR BIG PLAYS ALL GAME
LONG FROM
TYROIL SMOOCHIE-WALLACE.
- AND LET’S NOT FORGET
THE TIGHT ENDS,
IBRAHIM MOIZOOS
AND HINGLE MCCRINGLEBERRY.
THEY’VE BOTH
HAD AMAZING SEASONS.
- THAT’S RIGHT, GEOFF.
NOW LET’S MEET THE PLAYERS
FROM THE WEST. [rock music]
- SAGGITARIUTT JEFFERSPIN,
TEXAS A & M.
- D’GLESTER HARDUNKICHUD,
UNIVERSITY OF WISCONSIN.
- SWIRVITHAN L’GOODLING-SPLATT,
SASKATCHEWAN UNIVERSITY.
- QUATRO QUATRO, SAN JOSE
STATE UNIVERSITY.
- OZAMATAZ BUCKSHANK,
STANFORD UNIVERSITY.
- BEEZER TWELVE WASHINGBEARD,
JONES COLLEGE.
- SHAKIRAQUAN T.G.I.F. CARTER,
UNIVERSITY OF NORTHERN ARIZONA.
- X-WING @ ALICIOUSNESS,
MISSOURI WESTERN
STATE UNIVERSITY.
- SEQUESTER GRUNDELPLITH, M.D.,
ADAMS STATE.
- SCOISH VELOCIRAPTOR MALOISH,
SOUTH DAKOTA STATE UNIVERSITY.
- T.J. A.J. R.J.
BACKSLASHINFOURTH THE FIFTH,
ALBION COLLEGE.
- [squeals]
SAN DIEGO STATE UNIVERSITY.
- DONKEY TEETH,
BOISE STATE UNIVERSITY.
- TORQUE...
[jackhammer drilling]
LEWITH, NEVADA STATE...
PENITENTIARY.
- THE PLAYER FORMERLY KNOWN
AS MOUSECOP,
UNIVERSITY OF MISSOURI,
COLUMBIA.
- DAN SMITH, BYU.
- I'M DAVE SASSON ALONGSIDE JEFF
WORTHING,
AND WELCOME TO THE 2013
EAST/WEST BOWL,
WHERE WE'RE GOING TO BE WATCHING
SOME OF THE BEST
COLLEGE ATHLETES IN THE NATION
TRY TO PUT LAST YEAR'S
SPECTACLE TO SHAME.
- THAT'S RIGHT, DAVE.
IT WON'T BE EASY,
BUT THIS YEAR'S SENIORS
CERTAINLY WILL BE
TRYING TO GIVE LAST YEAR'S STARS
A RUN FOR THEIR MONEY.
LET'S CHECK OUT THE TEAMS,
STARTING WITH THE PLAYERS
FROM THE EAST.
[energetic rock music]
- COZNESSTER SMIFF,
RUTGERS UNIVERSITY.
- ELIPSES CORTER,
UNIVERSITY OF ALABAMA.
- NYQUILLUS DILLWAD, L.S.U.
- BISMO FUNYUNS,
FLORIDA STATE UNIVERSITY.
- DECATHOLAC MANGO,
GEORGIA TECH UNIVERSITY.
- MERGATROID SKITTLE,
UNIVERSITY OF LOUISVILLE.
- QUIZNATODD BIDNESS,
UNIVERSITY OF TENNESSEE.
- D'PEZ POOPSIE, OLE MISS.
- QUACKADILLY BLIP,
AUBURN UNIVERSITY.
- GOOLIUS BOOZLER, THE "U."
- BISQUITEEN TRISKET,
UNIVERSITY OF MICHIGAN.
- FARTRELL CLUGGINS,
UNIVERSITY OF ARKANSAS.
- BLYRONE BLASHINTON, SYRACUSE.
- CARTOONS PLURAL,
VIRGINIA TECH.
- JAMMIE JAMMIE-JAMMIE,
THE OHIO STATE UNIVERSITY.
- FUDGE.
- SOME OF THE BIG STORIES
THIS YEAR--
THE METEORIC RISE
OF D'PEZ POOPSIE,
AND LET'S NOT FORGET
ABOUT HEISMAN WINNER
JAMMIE JAMMIE-JAMMIE.
- AND REMEMBER, YOU CAN'T
TALK ABOUT 2013
WITHOUT BRINGING UP FUDGE.
EVERYBODY'S TALKING ABOUT FUDGE.
AT 350 POUNDS,
THIS RUNNING BACK IS ALMOST
UNSTOPPABLE THE WHOLE YEAR.
- YOU'RE RIGHT. I COULD TALK
ABOUT FUDGE ALL DAY.
BUT FIRST, LET'S MEET
THE PLAYERS FROM THE WEST.
[energetic rock music]
- EQUINE DUCKLINGS,
INDIANA UNIVERSITY,
PURDUE UNIVERSITY,
INDIANAPOLIS.
- DAHISTORIUS LAMYSTORIUS,
UTAH STATE UNIVERSITY.
- EWOKONIAD SIGOURNETH
JUNIORSTEIN,
OKLAHOMA STATE UNIVERSITY.
- EQQSQUIZITINE BUBLE
-SCHWINSLOW,
UNIVERSITY OF NEBRASKA.
- HUKA'LAKANAKA
HAKANAKAHCCKALUCKA'HUKAHAKAFAKA,
UNIVERSITY OF HAWAII.
- KING PRINCE CHAMBERMAID,
BAYLOR UNIVERSITY.
- LADENNIFER JADANISTON,
UNIVERSITY OF COLORADO.
- LADADADALADADADADADA DALA
-DADALADALADALADA,
UNIVERSITY OF ARIZONA.
- HARVARD UNIVERSITY,
DEVRY UNIVERSITY.
- [imitating rapid beeping]
ARMY/NAVY SURPLUS STORE.
- WINGDINGS, ONLINE CLASSES.
- [distorted voice] FIRSTNAME
LASTNAME, COLLEGE UNIVERSITY.
- GOD, HOMESCHOOL.
- SQUEEEEEEEEEPS,
SANTA MONICA COLLEGE.
- [British accent] BENEDICT
CUMBERBATCH, OXFORD UNIVERSITY.
- A.A. RON BALAKAY,
MOREHOUSE COLLEGE.
- HEY, JADINKALAGE?
- YEAH, L'CARPETRON?
- CHECK OUT LEOZ. I WONDER
WHAT HE'S DREAMING ABOUT?
- HE IS PROBABLY DREAMING
ABOUT WHAT WE
IS GONNA DO
TO THE TEAM FROM THE WEST.
- I WONDER.
-
♪ T'VARIUSNESS T-KING
FOR SHORT ♪
♪ I'M A BAD MAMMA-JAMMA
AND AN AWFUL SPORT ♪
♪ -
SMOOCHIE-WALLACE YOU CAN CALL ME
TYROIL RAPPIN' UP RUSHES
LIKE ALUMINUM FOIL
♪ ♪ -  MCCRINGLEBERRY
I'M VERY SCARY ♪
♪ IF I GOT THE BALL
YOU BEST BE WARY ♪
♪ -  L'CARPETRON DOOKMARRIOT
I LOVE THE BALL SO MUCH
I WANNA MARRY IT
♪ all: ♪
'CAUSE THE EASTERN
SCHOOL'S GONNA BEAT THE FOOLS
FROM THE WEST
♪ - OH, YEAH.
all: ♪
WHERE FOOTBALL'S CONCERNED
WE GONNA SHOW YOU
THAT WE ARE THE BEST
♪ ♪ -  WE ARE THE BEST
-  I'M IBRAHIM MOIZOOS ♪
♪ AND MY RHYMES ARE CLEAN
LIKE MY NAME IS DR. SEUSS ♪
♪ -  PROBINCRUZ III THEY CALL ME
"THE PROBE"
I CAN INTERCEPT BALLS
WITH MY EARLOBE
♪ ♪ -  SHOWER-HANDEL ♪
♪ THAT'S MY NAME
POWER CANDLE SOUNDS THE SAME ♪
♪ -  WITH JACKMERIUS
-  D'SQUARIUS
♪ ♪ -  AND JAVARISON-LAMAR ♪
♪ -  FLACKAWAXA PLAYS SAX
AND D'MARCUS PLAYS GUITAR ♪
all:
♪ 'CAUSE THE EASTERN SCHOOL'S ♪
♪ GONNA BEAT THE FOOLS
FROM THE WEST ♪
♪ -  OKAY DON'T YOU KNOW
♪ all: ♪
WHERE FOOTBALL'S CONCERNED
WE GONNA SHOW YOU
THAT WE ARE THE BEST
♪ ♪ -  INDEEDY,
WE ARE THE BEST ♪
- [gasps] IT MUST HAVE BEEN
ALL A DREAM.
[gasps] OR WAS IT?
- OH, IT'S ON.
♪ -  WHAT'S UP,
Y'ALL IT'S JEFFERSPIN
I'M THE BIG LEFT TACKLE
GONNA HELP US WIN
♪ ♪ -  X-WING AT ALYSSIUSNESS ♪
♪ I'LL USE MY FORCE
TO GIVE THE EAST DISTRESS ♪
♪ -  ALGERNON-SPLATTER'S
WHERE IT'S AT RUNNING ♪
♪ THROUGH DEFENDERS
AND PADDING MY STATS ♪
♪ -  Y'ALL KNOW ME
I'M WASHINGBEARD CATCH
SO MANY BALLS
IT'S A LITTLE WEIRD
♪ all: ♪
'CAUSE YOU KNOW WE GONNA
WIN AGAINST THE EAST
♪ ♪ -  LISTEN WHAT WE SAID
all: ♪
♪ WE GONNA GET THE MOST POINTS
AND THEY GONNA GET THE LEAST ♪
♪ -  JUST TRYIN' TO CALM THE
VOICES RUNNING THROUGH MY HEAD
♪ ♪ -  BACK IT UP
IT'S HARDUNKACHUD ♪
♪ I HIT THE Q.B. AND MAKE
A NOISE LIKE THUD ♪
♪ -  CAN'T BLOCK ME
AND ALL OF THAT JAZZ
'CAUSE Y'ALL DON'T WANT
NONE OF THIS OZAMATAZZ
♪ ♪ -  THE PLAYER...
-  TJ AJ ♪
♪ -  FORMERLY KNOWN...
♪ - [screeches]
[construction noises] ♪
♪ ♪ -  LOUITH
-  AS MOUSECOP ♪
♪ -  AND DONKEY TEETH
-  I'M THE TOUCHDOWN MAN
THAT'S GRUNDLEPLINTH
BUT Y'ALL AIN'T READY
FOR MY MAN DAN SMITH
♪ ♪ -
YO YO SMITH COMMA DANIEL ♪
♪ OTHER KICKERS IN THE LEAGUE
DON'T HOLD ♪
♪ A CANDLE CHEERLEADERS
UP ON MY CHOCOLATE CROTCH ♪
♪ THOSE GODDAMN BABY COCKER
SPANIEL B.Y.U. ♪
♪ WHY YOU BE MAD ♪
♪ 'CAUSE THE BITCHES
WANNA GET WITH ME GOT ♪
♪ SWISHER SWEETS AND DUTCHIES
ROLLIN' ON NO OTHER TEAM ♪
♪ CAN TOUCH
THESE HITTIN' FIELD GOALS ♪
♪ BLUNTED BEEN DRUNK
WHEN I PUNTED BEEN ♪
♪ LIKE A HUNDRED TIMES
THAT I ALREADY DONE IT ♪
♪ OH, [bleep] SEE
THESE HATERS THOUGHT ♪
♪ I WAS PLAYIN' STAYIN' AWAY
FROM MY FACES ♪
♪ WITH ALL THE BULL[bleep] ♪ ♪
THEY SAYIN' BUT JUST REMEMBER
WHO YOU TAUNTIN'
WHEN YOU TOSSIN' THOSE GAUNTLETS
I'M DAN SMITH AND THE WEST
IS GETTIN' ROWDY LIKE MONSTERS